Ці камери спостереження встановили не через крадіїв,
а через сусідів-поляків.
Вони націлені прямісінько у дитячу кімнату.
Ось тут видно камери.
Там ще одна, біла,
а он там чорна.
І  ось іще – бачите?
Ця прикра ситуація відбувається
у містечку Грейт Ярмут на сході Англії.
І це – не просто
побутовий конфлікт між сусідами.
Полячка Дорота Ренделл, яка консультує
потерпілу родину, колись приїхала
до Британії, аби влаштуватися на роботу в банку.
Але нині жінка допомагає
землякам у подоланні
специфічних проблем.
Господиня цієї квартири,
яку звати Агнєшка, не хоче показувати
обличчя. Вона побоюється,
що після цього нападки стануть ще гіршими.
Вона боїться, що на вулиці її впізнають.
Адже це маленьке місто.
І переслідування лише посиляться.
У неї п'ятеро дітей і вона хоче захистити
їх і себе.
Дорота Ренделл на власному досвіді
дізналася про примхи британської
бюрократії.
Але тепер вона допомагає писати скарги до поліції тим, хто отримує погрози за те,
що є громадянином не Британії, а ЄС.
Допомога проти ксенофобських проявів
потрібна дедалі більшій кількості людей.
Як-от Агнєшці
у випадку з відеокамерою спостереження.
Вона це зробила, щоб залякати нас.
Вона погрожувала нам
і на Фейсбуку. Казала: я вас бачу,
я за вами стежу!
Агнєшка із родиною мешкає на цій вулиці чотири роки.
Два роки тому сюди поселилась їхня
британська сусідка. Погрози почалися
після «брексіту».
І не лише з боку однієї цієї сусідки.
Раніше я мала проблеми у лікаря
або у школі. Тепер дітям дали
образливі прізвиська.
А діти ж повторюють те, що чують удома
від батьків! На вулиці там само боюся розмовляти
польською,
бо мене вже облаювали.
За її словами, один поліцейський порадив їй поїхати звідси.
Понад 70 відсотків мешканців
Грейт Ярмута проголосували за Brexit.
Курортне місто на Північному морі
належить до найбільш антиєвропейських
у Британії. У пабах та ресторанах
працює багато вихідців зі Східної Європи.
Ще більше їх – на аграрних
господарствах країни.
Прибічники Brexit підбурюють настрої
проти східноєвропейців.
Я нічого не маю проти іноземних працівників
з освітою. Але ті, що приїздять
сюди, не мають кваліфікації
та роблять не свою роботу за меншу
зарплатню, ніж місцеві!
І це обурливо!
Так, ідеться про імміграцію.
Особисто я не панікую – але достатньо багато людей
у Грейт Ярмуті стривожені.
Я нормально знаходжу з ними  спільну мову,
а вони зі мною.
Якби ж усе було так просто. Це Бірмінгем.
Як і скрізь у Великобританії,
тут регулярно відбуваються
зустрічі громадян ЄС,
щоб обговорити наслідки «брексіту».
Вони об‘єдналися
в ініціативу «Три мільйони» -
саме стільки громадян Євросоюзу
мешкає на острові.
Німці, французи,
поляки.
Кася Толбот познайомилась у Польщі
зі своїм чоловіком-британцем.
І вони переїхали сюди.
Раптом після Brexit стало недостатньо моїх
документів як європейки.
Тепер, щоб залишатися тут, мені потрібно
подбати про додаткові папери.
Кася забирає сина зі школи –
її діти народились у Британії.
Власне, у Бірмінгемі
традиційно було нормальне ставлення
до мігрантів з ЄС. Але у цій крамниці
фіш-енд-чіпс тепер усе змінилося.
Їм рано чи пізно слід поїхати геть.
Про це ж йшлося у випадку з Brexit.
І про наші гроші. Я вважаю,
чим більше людей сюди пропускають,
тим більше грошей іде звідси.
Ось про що йдеться!
Вона має на увазі громадян ЄС зі Східної Європи.
Кася Толбот тим часом отримала британський
паспорт.
Залишатися громадянкою ЄС було надто нестабільно.
Хоча її чоловік Джеймс працює священиком
і використав увесь свій авторитет,
справа вирішувалася
доволі натужно та
з багатогодинними телефонними розмовами.
Люди, які мають цей папір,
не уявляють собі, через які тортури
нам довелося пройти.
Якому тиску довелося протистояти.
Невідомо, що робила би польська родина
у Грейт Ярмуті без допомоги
Дороти Ренделл.
Знімальна група ДВ спробувала
вийти на контакт із сусідкою,
яка встановила камери спостереження.
Усередині було чути
ворушіння, але ніхто
так і не відчинив….